welcome to Hannity tonight we begin with
facts without fear we are broadcasting
live we're on the ground in New York
City where the USNS comfort a 1,000 bed
US naval hospital ship is now docked
this is a floating city it is massive
now normally stationed in Norfolk
Virginia and manned by highly trained
highly skilled members of the US Navy
the comfort will begin receiving
patients as early as tomorrow morning
the ship will serve as a support system
housing nan corona virus cases in order
to free up beds of koga 19 patients for
New York hospitals it is equipped with
12 operating rooms 1220 surgical
recovery rooms 80 intensive care beds
and 900 additional beds for other cases
now coming up the captain of the USNS
comfort will take us inside this
incredible ship an amazing floating
hospital now of course the enormous
surge in patients at New York hospitals
the USNS comfort is just one part of
what is a massive support effort now
underway all throughout New York and the
country at New York the city called the
Javits Center the Army Corps of
Engineers they have now just completed
the construction of a temporary hospital
with nearly 3,000 beds and they did it
record time multiply other temporary
hospitals surrounding New York are now
also being erected five of them and now
Friday the president approved four
additional emergency hospital sites
right inside New York City now all told
the US Army Corps of Engineers is
prepping over 100 sites nationwide to be
used as potential emergency hospitals
all in record time we are truly blessed
to live in a country with so many
amazing people this is all part of what
is the largest the single most
aggressive full-fledged response to beat
back the silent enemy before literally
we've never seen such mobilization of
forces against any pandemic ever in
history and now the great American
private sector they are mobilized Ford
and GM are now planning the production
of 50
and ventilators Oh that's coming up soon
General Motors will have 10,000 of those
we expect by mid-april and the
california-based Virgin orbit they are
now starting to mass-produce ventilators
as well should they be needed my pillow
Haynes Jockey Procter & Gamble Raytheon
and so many major companies
all-hands-on-deck ramping up the mass
production of mass and gloves and other
vital medical supplies and by the way
breaking today after getting emergency
approval from the fda abbott labs this
is huge
they have successfully created a test
for Colvin 19 that can get the American
people results in around 5 minutes and
every state will now receive at least 15
of avid's testing machines which can
perform up to 50,000 tests per day and
we have more good news from the
treatment point and the front there
we've been telling you about this anti
malaria drug will useful lupus as well
hydroxychloroquine has now been
authorized for emergency use nationwide
after promising results from several
preliminary studies now the
pharmaceutical giant Novartis which is
described you know one of those evil
pharmaceutical corporations by many
people on the left and in the media well
they're stepping up to they are donating
130 million doses of this drug for
treatment and meanwhile Israeli
pharmaceutical giant Teva has now
supplied the United States with six
million doses already I know the four
million reportedly on the way dr. oz
will weigh in and get this the phase 1
testing of a vaccine is already underway
this is a process that used to take
years they were able to break down the
sequence and this virus in about six
weeks I want to be clear make no mistake
everybody needs to buckle up we are
about to experience what will be a very
hard a very difficult a very emotionally
draining next couple of weeks the
numbers of infections numbers of deaths
they will continue to rise but if the
patterns we have seen elsewhere around
the world hold fluting China South Korea
now we're beginning to see it in Italy
and elsewhere
after that increase will see a leveling
off and then we hope for the precipitous
decline our health care system is facing
a massive health challenge we Americans
we are the United States home of them
over the brave when the land of the free
home of the brave that's us we're
already rising to the occasion now will
everything be perfect no absolutely not
but the entire country with the
exception of the usual suspects in the
media mob and of course do nothing
psychotic hate Trump Democrats the rest
of the country it's all hands on deck
it's a tribute to the great citizenry in
this country and thanks to American
ingenuity hard work determination we
will get through this we will recover we
will be better we will be stronger we
are rewriting the books on paradigms
right before our eyes a transformational
time and I guarantee you we won't be
calling a travel ban xenophobic and
fear-mongering and so on it's an
invisible enemy we have to win there's
no option but to win